is incredible I can't believe this when
a tragic accident takes a young man's
life what's going on is any of you okay
I thought it was the closest person to
press them but there are so many things
about him that I didn't know a mother
must search for answers I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to scare you I just say I
don't know it was Carrie this is Christy
Preston's ex-girlfriend no we work
together Preston and I are stone in fact
I live here you do yeah
but the deeper she digs I want nothing
to do with you have serious issues you
need help this doesn't sound much like
an invite to live with them does it the
more dirt she uncovers so what you're
telling us is that she knew exactly
where Preston was the morning of his
accident and what she's about to learn
how long did it reviewed eight nine ten
months a big mistake it's not keying my
cards killing like fish or vandalizing
my house why do you think she would lie
about moving in with Preston know who
goes to her crazing life is that some
women it was Preston fiancee
kind of game are you playing excuse me I
don't buy for one second that my son
proposed to you make killer girlfriends
oh I stepped on that a long time ago
largest entertainment presents Barbie
Castro Patrick Muldoon and Kate Manzi
two of your boyfriend's end up dead and
they're gonna suspect you
no they won't you're going to disappear
no body no crime
boyfriend killer
you